-Enjoy yourself. Enjoy yourself.
Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
It's a hot -- hot show tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is exciting.
One of the biggest performers
in the world --
Bad Bunny is here tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow!
-Bad Bunny is here.
He's been the most streamed
artist on Spotify
for the last three years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The only person
who streams more than that
is the Golden Bachelor.
The most streamed artist
on Spotify.
Now, if he only dated
Travis Kelce,
then he would be somebody.
That's right.
Bad Bunny is here.
And his new album
is already at number one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's called "Nadie Sabe
Lo Que Va a Pasar Mañana."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I actually learned Spanish so
that I'd know how to say that.
And, uh, I'm getting
pretty good at it.
Here. Watch this. Hola.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate it.
Well, let's get
to some news, guys.
After failing to get elected
Speaker of the House
twice this week,
Congressman Jim Jordan
said that he's not dropping out
and will keep running.
When Jordan said that
he was running a third time,
even Nike was like,
"Just don't."
Yep, Jordan wants
to be Speaker of the House
so that he doesn't
have to go back to his old job
of being the villain
in "Scooby-Doo."
[ Laughter ]
Guys, get this. Yesterday,
former President Trump
was in a New York City courtroom
for his civil fraud trial.
And during witness testimony,
the judge had to tell Trump
to lower his voice.
[ Laughter ]
Man.
Along with everything else,
it turns out Trump's rude.
Trump was like,
"This is me whispering!
Have you seen my tweets?!"
[ Laughter ]
The court --
[ Cheers and applause ]
The court stenographer was like,
"Where's the Caps Lock key?
Where's the...?"
Of course, when the judge said,
"Lower your voice,"
Trump was like, "Is this okay?"
Speaking of the former president
in court,
NBC just filed a request
to televise
Trump's upcoming
January 6th trial.
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
And there's
a nice little tie-in.
NBC asked that the trial be held
on the set of "Night Court."
-Oh.
-Hey, guys This is also great.
Charli D'Amelio
is on our show tonight.
Charli D'Amelio.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Charli D'Amelio has --
She has 151 million followers
on TikTok.
That's incredible. Yeah.
Everyone loves TikTok,
but sometimes you don't have
time to watch a whole video.
You just want to skip
right to the good part.
Well, it turns out you can.
For instance,
if you're watching a video,
you could skip this part.
-Happy birthday from Atlanta,
Zachary Michael!
-Yeah.
And just go right to this part.
-This time last year, you --
Oh, God! Oh, God!
Oh, no. Oh, God.
Not the plate.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Here's another example.
You could skip this part.
[ Sucking ]
-Oh...
-[ Audience groans ]
-And go right to this part.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. That's right.
You can skip this part...
-How much you pay for that taco?
-And go right to this part.
-You know what it is.
Boy's got his free taco.
[ Laughter ]
-"Don't worry about it."
-You know how it is.
♪ Boy's got a taco ♪
Here's another example.
You could skip this part.
And go right to this part.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And, finally,
you could skip this part.
-Oh...
-And go right to this part.
-Hey!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Dude. I swear. Yo, man.
He just blew his pants off.
Oh, my gosh.
Guys, switching gears, I saw
that the CEO of Costco
is stepping down.
[ Audience awws ]
Costco made the move after
realizing they could replace him
with a cheaper
Kirkland brand CEO.
[ Laughter ]
Just as good.
-Yeah.
-Some more business news today.
Uber Eats released
their annual cravings report,
and the most popular order
was French fries.
-Ooh!
-And drivers were like, "Yeah,
that's our favorite order, too."
"Oh, hey, your McDonald's
order came half-full.
Yeah. Sorry about that."
Meanwhile, the most popular
non-food items
were toilet paper,
emergency contraceptives,
and COVID tests.
Delivery guy was, "What the hell
is going on in that house?"
Guys, I read that
"Good Morning America"
is leaving their studio
in Times Square.
-Aww.
-Yeah, it makes sense.
It's hard delivering
serious news with a guy
in an M&M suit
dancing behind you.
[ Laughter ]
♪ Boy and his taco ♪
Well, guys, tonight
was an all-new episode
of "The Golden Bachelor."
We love that show here.
It's been very popular.
They're already looking
for their next lead.
Yeah, and we actually got ahold
of some of the audition tapes
from older men looking for love.
And it's really sweet.
Take a look at this.
-My name is Henry. I'm 71.
And I can't believe
I'm doing this,
but I am looking
for the love of my life.
-I'm Ted. I'm 64.
And I'm looking for someone
to spend
the rest of my life with.
-Hi. I'm Steve.
And I'm looking to date
about 28 women all at once.
-Haven't been married before.
Always wanted to, though.
-I lost my wife 15 years ago,
but she wanted me
to get back out there.
-I'm married now, but I have
an open kind of thing going on.
She doesn't "technically"
know it,
but I'm sure
she'd be cool with it.
-Well, my hobbies
are gardening and pickleball.
-I'm in a softball league
with some of my best friends.
-You guys don't do STD tests
before the show, right?
Or drug tests?
-I would love to be
the next Golden Bachelor.
-I hope you pick me
as the next Golden Bachelor.
-You know what?
I do not have an open marriage.
I'm kind of having second
thoughts about this thing.
So, you know, you're not gonna
air this anywhere, right?
This is just between us?
Okay. Alright. Alright.
I'll see you guys later.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And finally, I want to say
congrats to the Las Vegas Aces
for winning their second
WNBA title in a row!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes.
It was an exciting game,
and afterwards,
team owner Mark Davis
celebrated with the players.
Watch this.
[ Indistinct chanting ]
♪ Go, Mark, go, Mark, go, Mark ♪
♪ Go, Mark ♪
[ Laughter ]
They were like...
♪ No, really, Mark, just go,
go, Mark, go, Mark ♪
We have a great show!